Now there are just a few more nuances to the library and
steps we need to take before we can go from the source code of our
D3 visualization to a pretty graphic in the library.
We have seen the source of a complete D3 visualization,
in this case a horizontal bar chart, and
we have played around with D3 in a web browser console.
But how exactly do we go from a source file to what's displayed in
the web browser?
Every URL has four basic components.
Sometimes, if you're using a modern browser, Chrome included, they hide
the first part of http:// since it's often common across all URLs.
HTTP in this case, corresponds to the protocol that was used to load the page.
If you simply double-click on HTML file, with out going to a web server,
you may see file:// meaning that it was loaded with the file protocol.
The second portion of the URL, in this case,
localhost, corresponds to the host or server from which the file was loaded.
Since we're running a local web server to serve both our HTML and
our data, it's simply localhost, meaning the current machine.
The next section of the URL, which come after the colon, in this case 8000,
refers to the port.
If we think of our host, or
our server, as an apartment complex then the port would be
which individual unit of that apartment complex we would like to access.
So again the host might be the address of the apartment building and
the port might be the number of the apartment unit.
And finally what comes after the port in this
case let's_make_a_bar_chart.html is the file you'd like to load.